we're going to get away from the normal
show format a little bit just for today
most likely though we'll see what
happens with the rest of the week um
what what i want to do is go through
what we know so far and how i'm at least
processing some of this and thinking
about it
i can't tell you how you should process
it or think about it all i can do is
tell you
my own thoughts and i'm i'm desperately
hoping
that as i speak these words they will
not be made irrelevant by events
developing in real time
of course it's better for the country if
we get legitimate
clarity and closure but it would be bad
for the reach of this
episode of my podcast and really what's
more important the country or my podcast
it's a toss-up at least i think we can
all agree on that so
um in any case let's talk about what we
know
um we know that there was no democrat
blue wave landslide there was no
overwhelming repudiation of the evil
orange man the american people did not
run smiling and weeping with open arms
towards marxism
there was also no republican land side
though no credible person was
forecasting or expecting that
no credible person was forecasting a
democrat landslide either
though lots of lots of people were
forecasting and just no credible people
were
it's the problem is that most of the
people who do the forecasting in
politics
just like most the people who do the
forecasting of our weather
are not credible and not reliable and
are more or wrong more often than
they're not
in this case as you've probably heard
the the polls were absurdly wrong
especially in states like florida and
also elsewhere in the country as i said
on the election special last night if
you watch that on dailywire.com
at this point we have to view pollsters
the same way we view
like hotline psychics a person who
identifies themselves as a pollster
ought to be
greeted with all of the same respect and
deference
as miss cleo i'll put it this way if
pollsters still have a job after this
election then i want to be one
i am leaving the daily wire to work to
be a pollster
or maybe i could be the daily wires
official pollster it
you know it would mean that i can say
whatever i want i can be wrong nearly
100
of the time and still get paid which on
second thought
already pretty much describes what i do
so i guess i don't need to change but
either way the polls are a laughingstock
and you will be a laughingstock yourself
from henceforth should you quote them
why are the polls wrong well maybe the
methodology behind drawing sweeping
conclusions about hundreds of millions
of people based on
phone conversations with 900 registered
voters is fundamentally flawed
and maybe there are only certain kinds
of people who will even talk to a
pollster in the first place
and that selection bias makes the
conclusion useless
maybe it has something to do with all
that i don't know what else do we know
we know that president trump win or lose
actually made gains with minority voters
especially hispanics
we know that the democrats massively
underperformed in important senate races
republicans seem poised to keep the
senate
again even if biden wins these are major
defeats for the democrats
why did it happen this way well there
are a number of easy answers
they ran a guy who has dementia for one
thing that's a problem
that has to factor in the democrat party
also over the last several years
rather than expanding their coalition to
bring more people under the tent
has done the opposite and narrowed their
message and appeal
at this point seemingly trying to target
a coalition of
media pundits college professors
19 year old white girls who have nose
rings and dye their hair on natural
colors and blm activists
of course there's a lot of crossover in
those groups i mean those some people
are all of those things
but um that's been their focus critical
race theory gender theory screaming
incessantly about america's evil past
systemic racism transgender
eight-year-olds
these are the kinds of issues and
arguments and ideas and concepts that
the democrat party has presented
it doesn't have a wide appeal it turns
out the appeal is certainly wider than
i'd like for it to be because i think it
should have
an appeal that extends to zero people
but it's not as wide as the democrats
thought and hoped
when it comes to the minority vote
specifically we know that the left ever
since the formation of black lives
matter has decided
that black lives matter the organization
is the same as
black people the two are interchangeable
in the minds of the left which is why if
you criticize black lives matter as i'm
sure you've noticed
you're also criticizing black people
according to them
it's racist to attack blm they told us
because they draw
no distinction between blm the
organization and the demographic group
it supposedly represents
but there is a distinction just look at
what blm stands for
defeating the nuclear family trans
rights that sort of thing
these aren't the priorities of average
black voters and black families
these aren't the priorities of average
voters and families of any race
but democrats put all black people into
that box operating as if
to be black is to be a radical leftist
this is a failing strategy and they're
losing their grip on the minority vote
because of it
and that again is the case no matter how
this election shakes out
but of course all signs point to
leftists learning exactly the opposite
sorts of lessons here
like here's a tweet from a democrat
operative on twitter david adkins
he says progressives will recriminate
against centrists and vice versa but all
dem factions have to contend with this
turnout was high the prague base showed
up like prague's want
there was huge cross-partisan outreach
like moderates want
but trump activated a massive racist
sexist vote
i hate to admit it but this election is
less about what anyone on the left
center
left center center-left did wrong but
rather
than the extraordinary challenge we have
in defeating this fascist movement
sure there are things we can do better
immediately most especially dealing with
what went wrong with the hispanics
latino vote figuring out how to close
the gap between our candidates and
support for progressive
issues but there frankly aren't a lot of
great options because what it looks like
right now
is that dems were soft with poc men who
like
trump's toxic masculinity do we really
want to cater to that
pander more to the anti-chavistas
dial back our effort on police reform
and submit to the blue line flag folks
no easy answers if your answer is to go
farther to the center
you have to deal with the reality that
neither the biden nor clinton strategies
really worked
the cross-partisan alliance of decency
didn't materialize if your answer is to
go farther left well look at florida or
the rust belt the bright side
the country is clearly trending away
from from them the senate and electoral
college are saving them
but it's not trending away fast enough
to overcome an enormous backlash from
people
who simply refuse to give up white
supremacy toxic masculinity
and hardcore evangelical bible thumping
who are literally happy to suffer
hypothermia and die with tubes in their
throats for it
did you get that the problem is that a
lot of minorities are sexist
america is racist everyone's a bigot and
the solution presumably is to be even
louder and more obnoxious hectoring
scolds and to work harder to get men
especially black men to hate themselves
and their masculinity
yes that's the key that's the ticket
glad to see they've learned something or
actually they've learned nothing
whatsoever
well hope you enjoyed that clip from the
matt walsh show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content